a six one seven eight three zero 4750 we
are going to go to our next caller from
the 507 area code who's this from 507 hi
David
I am Groot your name is Groot you said
yeah alright go ahead my group uh I was
wondering what you make of the news that
trey gowdy will not be seeking
re-election and what that means for the
Nunez memo and and if you know what
what's gonna be happening next with the
whole story well I think that the
reports right now and more might be
known about this by the time the show
goes out today the reports are that the
new Ness memo is going to be released at
some point relatively soon that it's
just it's going to be released and we're
going to see what's in it as far as trey
gowdy not seeking re-election he has
become like a cult hero in the
Republican Party because of his very
prosecutorial type series of questions
during hearings but quite frankly I
don't know that we've ever really
learned anything from those
question-and-answer sessions and I think
it's basically showboating I don't care
I mean go ahead and quick trey Gowdy it
doesn't really make a difference to me
it sounds to me like the exact same
thing as to what happened to jason
Chaffetz right he's the investigator in
chief against Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama yeah but now that you're in a
position where you have to investigate
the Republican president you don't want
to do it anymore so chiefess is
resigning and trey gowdy now to Gowdy as
well yeah no but I listen I look the
memo thing it's become this this sort of
litmus test where on the Internet if
you're not constantly just talking about
releasing the memo you're in some way
part of some kind of official list or
corporate media cover-up of the truth or
whatever
listen figure out whether the memo can
or can't be released let's figure out
what's in the memo let's make sure we're
careful about classified information
which supposedly was one of the big
reasons not to vote for Hillary Clinton
that she was careless with classified
information now everybody wants this
memo released regardless of what's in
there and then let's evaluate what's in
the memo and I still am having a hard
understanding how it relates to the
credibility of Muller's investigation
you know group right I just wondered if
you saw that Gaudi dropping out and
trying to swing away basically from the
whole thing yeah which would discredit
the entire memo and I don't think it'll
discredit it we just got to see the memo
and see what's in there
all right groot appreciate the call
thank you very much